der titel des heutigen videos der war
echt schwierig zu finden weil er dem
super spannenden thema gerecht werden
musste und euch auch dafür interessieren
sollte man es wirklich sehr wichtig es
geht um drogensucht und meinen damit
verbundenen superkräfte und wie man mit
einer impfung von der drogensucht
loskommen kann also alles super spannend
sind klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen also um es vorweg zu nehmen
ich habe tatsächlich eine etwas seltsame
eigenschaft man könnte sie als
superkräfte bezeichnen also was bei mir
wirklich seltsam ist bei mir wirken
drogen einfach nicht ich hab ich schon
einiges genommen aber nichts wirkt außer
alkohol von dem werde ich tatsächlich
betrunken aber alles andere hat bei mir
einfach keine wirkung egal was ich nehme
es passiert einfach nichts letztlich in
amsterdam musste ich einen ganzen joint
rauchen weil die leute es einfach nicht
glauben wollten und auch da es passierte
nichts rein gar nichts und das ist
natürlich super ob es superkräfte sind
naja aber es hat schon vorteile ich kann
nie drogensüchtig werden das ist
natürlich wirklich klasse aber das ist
jetzt auch für jeden möglich und es ist
vielleicht die erklärung für meine
unempfindlichkeit für drogen
forscherinnen und forscher um kinder und
port bremer vom scripps research
institute in den usa haben jetzt einen
impfstoff gegen heroin entwickelt und
der funktioniert tatsächlich wie eine
impfung
sie hat das team den wirkstoff an
rhesusaffen getestet sie verwendeten
abgeschwächte heroin moleküle die sie an
einen tetanus bestandteil als träger
banken
dieser wirkstoff sollte das immunsystem
trainieren das heroin als fremdkörper zu
erkennen und entsprechende antikörper zu
bilden und tatsächlich bildeten die
affen spezielle antikörper die sich an
das heroin an lagerten und so
verhinderten dass das heroin die
blut-hirn-schranke überwinden konnte
der rausch blieb aus bei tests
funktioniert er das perfekt und die
wirkung des heroins wurde um das
fünfzehnfache abgeschwächt und der
impfstoff wirkte sogar mindestens acht
monate lang jetzt wollen die forscher
und forscherinnen erste klinische tests
mit menschen machen die genehmigung
dafür müsste es schnell geben denn alle
bestandteile des impfstoffs sind bereits
bei anderen anwendungen zugelassen das
wäre ein sehr vielversprechender weg um
heroin abhängige von der droge los
zu lassen aber das beste ist natürlich
erst gar nicht drogenabhängig zu werden
deshalb respekt vor drogen und egal ob
alkohol haschisch mdma täter und so
weiter und so fort seit extrem
vorsichtig drogen sind nichts tolles
weil sie ja wohlbefinden nur simulieren
sich richtig wohlfühlen das ist das
allerbeste
denn von drogen wieder loszukommen ist
wirklich sehr schwierig diese impfung
wird es in zukunft ausschließlich für
heroin geben ob andere wirkstoffe noch
für andere drogen gefunden werden das
steht noch in den sternen wir werden
euch natürlich hier informieren wenn es
etwas neues gibt
wer nichts verpassen wollt dann drückt
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier also hier
geht es weiter mit einem komplett
betrunken christoph und meinem
alkoholtest mit vielen infos zu der
droge wer mich also mal volltrunken
sehen wollt dann nur zu klicks auf das
video und habt euren spaß ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran